joachim kokaté des conseiller spécial de
la présidence centrafricaine
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors la minustah la
mission des nations unies en
centrafrique se dit en alerte maximale à
quel point la situation sécuritaire
s'est dégradée en centrafrique
oui madeleine pour le second tout ce que
je peux vous dire c'est vrai que la
situation sécuritaire s'est dégradée à
34 chine que à l'offensive des troupes
armées organisé par l'ancien chef d'état
le disque françois bozizé yangouvonda et
que nous avons les preuves alors à
partir de ce moment là le gouvernement a
pris des dispositions nécessaires pour
organiser la sécurisation et le
rétablissement de la sécurité dans tout
le pays et le gouvernement vous l'avez
dit accuse donc à l'ancien président
françois bozizé d'être derrière ce coup
d'état
le parti de françois bozizé qui dément
cette information
vous dites que vous détenez des preuves
comment s'assurer de l'implication de
l'ancien chef d'état
derrière ce coup d'état il ya des
voyageurs il ya des images vidéo
organisé par l'unm de francs soit
produit dans son fief 400 voix en
organisant le scruteront des jeunes eux
sans trafic a atterri mouvement et amap
addition des béarnais ramenant les
mercenaires interdite dans notre pays
en donnée le 3 en délire aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que tout est
réuni en centrafrique pour que les
élections du 27 décembre se déroule
sereinement dans le calme et dans la
sécurité
les élections vont avoir lieu de 24
défendre et de souhaits de tous les
centrafricains et je pense que les
sucres soit bozizé yangouvonda était
aussi dans cette logique les tours
la cour constitutionnelle a tranché pour
dire que monsieur françois de diagonale
ne pourra pas être incarné la détection
l'élection présidentielle au des raisons
que lui même n'y fait il connaît les
exactions dont il a eu à connaître on
dans tout son règne
et alors il a vu qu'il est autonome et
le personnel au dessus de la justice la
décision de la cour constitutionnelle
moi à ma connaissance et tu coûtes chef
du gouvernement
nous tous nous sommes sereins que les
élections auront lieu parce que les
conditions sont réunies dégâts et les
pertes ont atteint des tissus qui a
vendu dans un derby donc
il y aura les élections quelquefois ils
avaient parié sur le terrain la force
reste à la loi et nous sommes en train
d'organiser milliers de profs d'état de
l'huile toutes les poches de résistance
joachim kokaté merci d'abord être avec
toi en direct sur arte france on
rappelle que vous êtes conseiller
spécial de la présidence centrafricaine
mercier est fou